המונח טלפורטציה קוונטית אולי נשמע כמו משהו ממדע בדיוני, אבל כמו שנדבר על זה בפרק של היום
של Qiskit in the Classroom, זו טכניקה אמיתית מאוד ומאוד שימושית לתקשורת קוונטית ו
רשתות. ברוכים הבאים ל-Qiskit in the Classroom. בסדרה הזו, נשתמש ב-Qiskit כדי לחקור כמה מושגים בסיסיים
שנלמדים בדרך כלל בקורסים הקשורים למחשוב קוונטי. כל סרטון מלווה במודול אינטראקטיבי
שמקושר בתיאור למטה, אז בטוח תבדקו את זה. טלפורטציה היא סוג של טרופ של מדע בדיוני ופנטזיה
בשלב הזה. בן אדם או חפץ נעלם ממיקום אחד ומיד מופיע במקום אחר.
כמה שזה היה מגניב, לצערנו, סוג כזה של טלפורטציה לפחות הוא בלתי אפשרי. זה היה שובר את מגבלת המהירות הקוסמית
שום דבר לא יכול לנסוע מהר יותר מאור. אבל טלפורטציה קוונטית היא
אפשרית. בטלפורטציה קוונטית, מידע ולא חומר יכול להיות מועבר בין שני
מיקומים רחוקים. כל מה שצריך זה זוג חלקיקים שזורים, אחד בכל אתר, ודרך להעביר מידע קלאסי
בין שני האתרים. הפרוטוקול הזה פותח ב-1993 על ידי צוות
של מדעני קוונטים, כולל Charles Bennett מ-IBM. הם קראו לזה טלפורטציה קוונטית כי בדומה לגרסה
של המדע הבדיוני, המידע הקוונטי נעלם ממיקום אחד והופיע במיקום רחוק אחר
בלי שאי פעם עבר דרך המרחב שביניהם. זה אולי נשמע כמו קסם, אבל כמו שנראה, אין שום דבר
מסתורי או קסום בזה. זה מתאפשר על ידי התופעה של שזירה קוונטית יחד עם תקשורת
קלאסית. היום נעבור על פרוטוקול הטלפורטציה הקוונטית ואיך הוא עובד. ואז נעביר את זה ל
פעולה על מחשב קוונטי אמיתי כדי לשגר את המצב של qubit מצד אחד של מעבד קוונטי של IBM לצד
אחר. אז ככה טלפורטציה קוונטית עובדת. נניח שיש לנו שני אנשים Alice ו-Bob שמופרדים
על ידי מרחק גדול. נגיד ל-Alice יש qubit. נקרא ל-qubit Q בשביל הנוחות. והוא נמצא באיזשהו
מצב קוונטי לא ידוע sq כאשר אלפא 0 ואלפא 1 הם מספרים מרוכבים
Alice רוצה לשלוח את המצב שלה ל-Bob, אבל אין לה דרך לשלוח את ה-qubit עצמו. יכול להיות ש
הוא רחוק מדי, או אולי היא אפילו לא יודעת בדיוק איפה Bob נמצא, אז היא לא יודעת לאן לשלוח את זה. למזלם,
החברים כבר חולקים זוג של qubit-ים שזורים A ו-B, כאשר ל-Alice יש qubit A ול-Bob יש qubit B. וה-
qubit-ים האלה שזורים. כשאני אומר שזורים, אני מתכוון שלמרות ששני ה-qubit-ים מופרדים על ידי מרחק גדול
המצבים שלהם מתואמים בדרך שהפיזיקה הקלאסית לא יכולה להסביר. הזוג השזור הזה הוא
משהו שנקרא Ebit, שאפשר להשתמש בו כמשאב במחשוב קוונטי ותקשורת.
במקרה הזה, Alice יכולה להשתמש ב-EBIT כמשאב כדי להעביר את המידע הקוונטי שלה ל-Bob. כדי לראות איך, בואו
נתחיל לרשום את המצב המשותף של שלושת ה-qubit-ים האלה כאשר סידרתי את ה-qubit-ים בצורה קצת שרירותית
בשלב הזה, אבל הסדר הזה יהיה נוח כשנריץ את הניסוי שלנו ב-Qiskit. ב-Qiskit, הדרך הסטנדרטית לסדר
את ה-qubit-ים היא מימין לשמאל. אז, המצב של qubit אפס יופיע בצד ימין.
בואו נרחיב קצת את המצב ונכתוב אותו מחדש ככה. ואז הצעד הראשון בפרוטוקול הטלפורטציה שלנו הוא
של Alice לשזור את ה-qubit של הנתונים שלה עם החצי שלה של ה-EBIT qubit באמצעות gate של C-NOT. gate של C-NOT או controlled-NOT
gate ישנה את המצב של qubit אחד, ה-qubit המטרה, בהתאם למצב של qubit אחר, ה-qubit השולט.
אם ה-qubit השולט במצב אפס, אז שום דבר לא קורה למטרה. ואם ה-qubit השולט במצב
אחד, אז ה-qubit המטרה מתהפך. אז במקרה הזה, ה-qubit של הנתונים של Alice שהוא Q יהיה ה-qubit השולט ו
ה-Ebit qubit A שלה יהיה ה-qubit המטרה. אז שני האיברים הראשונים לא השתנו בכלל מה-C-NOT, אבל
שני האיברים האחרונים כן כי ה-qubit השולט Q היה במצב אחד. ואז Alice
תפעיל Hadamard gate על ה-qubit של הנתונים שלה Q שלוקח את מצב 0 למצב 1/2 של 0 + 1 ואת מצב 1 ל
1 חלקי 2 של 0 פחות 1. אני הולך לדלג על קצת אלגברה פשוטה פה שאתם יכולים לנסות למלא לבד אם אתם רוצים.
אבל אחרי שמסדרים מחדש כמה איברים תקבלו מצב שנראה ככה. אז עכשיו המצב של שלושת ה-qubit-ים של Alice ו-Bob
השזורים נראה כמו בלגן מוחלט. אבל תראו מה קורה אם Alice מודדת את שני ה-qubit-ים שלה. מצב שלושת
ה-qubit-ים יקרוס חלקית לאחד מארבעת האיברים
האלה. ובכל מקרה, Bob יישאר עם מצב סופרפוזיציה עם אמפליטודות שקשורות למצב הלא ידוע
המקורי של Alice. זכרו שהאמפליטודות הן אלפא 0 ואלפא 1. אז
לדוגמה, אם Alice מודדת את שני ה-qubit-ים כאפס, אז המצב של Bob יקרוס לאיבר הזה, המצב הלא ידוע
המקורי ש-Alice רצתה לשגר. אבל אם Alice מודדת אפס על qubit A ואחד על qubit Q, אז המצב של
Bob יהיה זה. את המצב הזה אפשר להפוך למצב המקורי של qubit Q אם Bob
מפעיל Z gate, שיהפוך את הסימן פה. אבל Bob לא יידע לעשות את זה
עד שהוא ילמד מה Alice מדדה. אז הצעד הבא בפרוטוקול הוא ש-Alice תתקשר ל-Bob ותגיד לו מה
שתי המדידות שלה היו. אחרי שהוא ידע את זה, הוא ידע אילו פעולות לבצע על ה-qubit שלו כדי שיתאים
למצב המקורי של Alice. הנה טבלה של ארבע המדידות האפשריות וארבע הפעולות האפשריות ש-Bob
יצטרך לבצע על ה-qubit שלו על סמך המדידות האלה. Bob עלול להצטרך להפעיל Z gate, X gate, או את שניהם כדי
להפוך את ה-qubit שלו כך שיתאים ל-qubit המקורי של Alice. הצעד האחרון הזה, שבו Alice מתקשרת ל-Bob, אגב, זו הסיבה ש
טלפורטציה קוונטית לא מפרה סיבתיות. למרות שהמצב של Bob קרס מיידית כש-Alice מדדה
את ה-qubit-ים שלה, Bob לא יכל להוציא שום מידע מהמצב הזה עד ש-Alice אמרה ל-Bob מה היא מדדה. ו
השיחה הזו הייתה מוגבלת על ידי מהירות האור. עברנו הרבה מתמטיקה מפורטת, אז העובדה המדהימה
שזה עתה שיגרנו מידע קוונטי אולי הלכה לאיבוד. אבל זה באמת מדהים. על ידי שימוש
בשזירה כמשאב, Alice יכלה לבצע מדידה כדי להרוס מידע קוונטי שאוחסן אצלה ולגרום לו
להופיע במיקום רחוק אחר אצל Bob. המרחק הזה יכול להיות מאות, אפילו אלפי קילומטרים. ויותר
מדהים, הפרוטוקול הזה אפילו לא דורש ש-Alice תדע בדיוק איפה Bob נמצא. כל עוד הם חולקים Ebit
והם יכולים לתקשר באופן קלאסי אחד עם השני, טלפורטציה קוונטית תעבוד. עכשיו, בואו נראה איך זה עובד
עם Qiskit ובאמת לשגר מצב קוונטי על מחשב קוונטי.
נתחיל עם שלושה qubit-ים, אחד לכל אחד מ-qubit הנתונים Q וה-qubit-ים A ו-B שירכיבו את ה-E bit. אנחנו
מתחילים ביצירת ה-E bit. מפעילים Hadamard על qubit A ואחריו C-NOT
בין A ו-B כדי ליצור את המצב השזור שאנחנו מחפשים.
ואז אנחנו מכינים את ה-qubit של Alice שהוא Q במצב קוונטי אקראי על ידי הפעלת יוניטרי אקראי שמוצג בתיבה הזו עם התווית
U. ואז מגיעה הטלפורטציה. קודם ה-C-NOT בין qubit-ים Q ו-A. ואז ה-Hadamard על
qubit Q. ואז המדידות גורמות לקריסה חלקית של המצב כך שרק ה-qubit של Bob שהוא B נמצא במצב סופרפוזיציה.
זו הנקודה שבה Alice הייתה מתקשרת ל-Bob ואומרת לו מה היא מדדה. ואז Bob היה מפעיל כמה
gate-ים בהתאם למדידות האלה. התיבות האלה עם המסגרת האדומה מסמנות gate-ים מותנים. הראשון אומר
ש-Bob מפעיל X gate על ה-qubit שלו אם qubit A נמדד כאחד. ו
השני אומר שהוא יפעיל Z gate גם אם qubit Q נמדד כאחד.
אז עכשיו ל-Bob אמור להיות qubit באותו מצב שה-qubit של Alice היה בו בנקודה הזו אחרי ה-gate היוניטרי.
אם הכל הלך לפי התוכנית, אז שיגרנו את המצב הקוונטי. אבל איך בודקים את זה? אפשר להריץ את אותו
circuit אבל לעשות שינוי קטן אחד.
פה הוספנו עוד יוניטרי ממש בסוף ה-circuit שמופעל על ה-qubit של Bob. היוניטרי הזה הוא ההופכי של
זה שהפעלנו בהתחלה על ה-qubit של Alice. ההיגיון פה הוא שאם ה-gate הראשון יצר את
המצב הקוונטי שעכשיו שוגר ל-qubit של Bob, אז זה אמור לבטל את זה, ולהחזיר את ה-qubit של Bob למצב
אפס. אבל כמובן, זה מבטל את כל העבודה הקשה שלנו של שיגור המצב מלכתחילה. אז לא היינו רוצים
לעשות את זה אם באמת רצינו לעשות משהו עם המצב המשוגר ואם הוא באמת היה במצב קוונטי לא ידוע
לא היינו יכולים להפעיל יוניטרי כדי לבטל את זה. בכל מקרה, זה אך ורק למטרות אבחון כדי לוודא
שהטלפורטציה הצליחה. אם נמדוד את ה-qubit של Bob במצב אפס, אז נוכל להיות בטוחים באופן סביר
שהטלפורטציה עבדה. ברגע שנהיה בטוחים שהפרוטוקול שלנו עובד כצפוי, נוכל להסיר את היוניטרי
הסופי הזה ובאמת לעשות משהו עם המצב המשוגר. אבל לעת עתה, בואו רק נוודא שזה עובד. בואו
נריץ את ה-circuit על מחשב קוונטי. אפשר להשתמש ב-Qiskit primitive sampler כדי להריץ את ה-circuit הזה
הרבה פעמים ולאסוף סטטיסטיקות על תוצאות המדידה. אם שיגרנו בצורה מושלמת את המצב של Alice ל-Bob כל
פעם, אז Bob היה מודד את ה-qubit שלו כאפס כל פעם, אבל עם רעש סביבתי ואי-דיוקים ב
gate-ים, אפשר לצפות לראות כמה הרצות שבהן ה-qubit של Bob מסתיים כאחד. אבל כל עוד רוב הזמן
ה-qubit של Bob נמדד כאפס, אפשר לקרוא לזה הצלחה. פה יש לנו היסטוגרמה של תוצאות המדידה של
כל שלושת ה-qubit-ים. המדידה של Bob מוצגת במיקום הראשון של כל מחרוזת של שלושה ביטים. כצפוי, ארבע
התוצאות שמתאימות לביט שלו כאפס הן הרבה יותר סבירות מארבע האחרות. אז, שיגרנו בהצלחה
מצב קוונטי. אבל תראו כמה רחוק שיגרנו. זו מפה של כל
ה-qubit-ים על המעבד הקוונטי שבו השתמשנו. ובניסוי, השתמשנו רק בשלושת ה-qubit-ים האלה.
ה-qubit של Alice היה פה וה-qubit של Bob היה פה. אז, הם היו כמעט ממש אחד ליד השני. יכולנו
להשיג את אותו דבר פשוט על ידי הפעלת כמה swap gate-ים, שכמו שהשם מרמז, פשוט מחליפים את המצבים הקוונטיים
של שני qubit-ים שכנים. טלפורטציה קוונטית שימושית להעברת מידע קוונטי למרחקים גדולים, ו
מצבים קוונטיים שוגרו מאות קילומטרים בעבר. עבור הניסויים שלנו כאן, אנחנו מוגבלים על ידי
גודל השבב, אבל נוכל לעשות את הטלפורטציה קצת יותר מרשימה על ידי שיגור מצב בין שני
qubit-ים רחוקים על המחשב הקוונטי שלנו. אז, בואו ננסה את זה. הנה תרשים ה-circuit החדש שלנו. הוא נראה קצת יותר
מסובך, אבל שום דבר לא השתנה באופן מהותי חוץ מזה שעכשיו Alice ו-Bob יוצרים את ה-EBIT המשותף שלהם,
ואז נפרדים. סדרת הקווים והאיקסים האלה מייצגת swap gate-ים שמזיזים
את המצבים של Alice ו-Bob מ-qubit אחד לאחר. Alice זזה למעלה ל-qubit 1 ו
Bob זז למטה ל-qubit 12. ואז Alice יוצרת את המצב האקראי שלה על qubit 0 עם
היוניטרי הזה. שימו לב שהיא יוצרת את המצב אחרי שהיא ו-Bob כבר
נפרדו. אז Bob כבר רחוק ממנה.
ואז פרוטוקול הטלפורטציה ממשיך כמו קודם ו-Bob מסיים עם המצב המקורי של Alice אחרי הפעולות
המותנות שלו. מפעילים את ה-gate היוניטרי ההופכי ואז בודקים שה-qubit של Bob נמצא
במצב אפס. ושוב אנחנו רואים שרוב הזמן ה-qubit של Bob נמצא במצב
אפס. אז הטלפורטציה הצליחה.
שיעור ההצלחה לא בדיוק גבוה כמו כש-Alice ו-Bob היו אחד ליד השני, אבל. כל ה-swap gate-ים האלה
יכולים להיות יקרים ולגרום ל-EBIT להידרדר קצת. טלפורטציה קוונטית אולי נראית כמו קסם, אבל כמו שראינו,
כל מה שצריך זה שזירה, ערוץ תקשורת קלאסי, וקצת חוכמה. ההצעה המקורית מ-1993
שכיסינו בסרטון הזה הניחה את הבסיס לפרוטוקולים אחרים כמו gate טלפורטציה
קוונטית והיא מרכיב חיוני למחשוב קוונטי ותקשורת.
בחזית הניסויית, מדענים המשיכו לדחוף את הגבולות של טלפורטציה קוונטית, ואפילו הצליחו לשגר
את המצב הקוונטי של פוטון בין מעבדה על כדור הארץ ללוויין במרחק 1,400 ק"מ
מעליה. ולשגר מצבים קוונטיים דרך כבל אינטרנט קלאסי רועש. אם אתם רוצים לשגר מצב קוונטי
משלכם, לכו למודול הטלפורטציה הקוונטית שמקושר בתיאור למטה. תודה שצפיתם
ונתראה בפעם הבאה.